got to try to pee it off sometimes you
don't and then sometimes you walk away
and you go I just got to get better next
time I got to get better next time but
the real game is leaving the seat down
and still being able to hit all the
Poo so have you guys ever heard of the
Osborne Tire Reef no what is that I know
[__] Osborne from Spider-Man oh let's
talk about
that so the OD that funny ni it just
caught off guard and I would love talk
about Harry Osborne dude that's his name
right talking about har we're talking
about Harry Osborne for the next p talk
about the green go bunch of tires
underwater and then it created a natural
Reef yeah a natural Reef which is way
cooler than Spider-Man talk by the way
you tell me you tell me if it's natur
might be how's this got a glider oh it
does it look [__] you [__] killed
Aunt May spoiler alert what why is there
so many tires that's crazy did the
Michelin Man get like did he get what
did he eat all those what happened to
the Michelin Man did he go out there to
eat all that and he [__] it out oh
that's what that could be he eats tires
right that's to eat it all and [__] it
out the Michelin Man he eats all the
tires he's also made out of tires too
right he's made out of tires yeah sense
he would [__] them out um so in the
1970s and 80s Spider-Man would have been
this was a an idea that some
environmentalists had to litter to mimic
the benefits of coral reefs using old
tires in places that didn't have coal
Reef no [__] way is that a real thing
yeah a real thing so they're littering
tires um that's so stupid that's they
did this this local nonprofit they they
created the Osborne Reef by dropping
more than 2 million tires into Florida's
Coastal water a nonprofit did this
nonprofit did this they're [__]
thought did they really think it was
going to it because Coral grows on
rubber it was to be a fish habitat like
replacing to mimic Coral mimic Coral
like fish habitats right yeah so they
can go like inside and around and like
doesn't stuff grow off of coral that
like Coral alive and they eat the stuff
on the coral why the [__] would that
work cuz they're stupid back then wait
are they stupid back then or are they
smart now cuzz the argument is that a
lot of the ideas that these guys have
end up not panning out and becoming
gigantic waste factories like [__]
the the what do you call them um the
wind farms dude this is the biggest scam
of all time yeah this one you know the
uh did that work to million the [__] no
there's so much toxic [__] that comes
out of tires if that happened in the 70s
and that picture is now there's no fish
or anything around no no [__] way
don't they recycle tires this project
was also approved by the US Army by the
US Army Corps of Engineers and The
Dumping operation was supervised by US
Navy mine sweeper also good gear which
provided a lot of the tires they even
christened the reef like they were doing
such a great thing by dropping a
goldplated tire into the ocean from a
Goodyear blimp this is like a whole
thing wow sounds like 7s Bud right
that's kind of that's kind of tight
though like we're going to drop a gold
tire from the blimp of course so all
these tires right they were held
together only with nlon rope and steel
clips and they started coming loose of
course which means the reef started just
blowing around with the current and so
the tires didn't stay in that one
location they ended up getting scattered
all over the waters in Florida wow so
now they're trying to figure out how to
get the tires out and they're trying to
kill our [__] straws and they doing
[__] like that
bro I got to drink BR back straw I even
drink to a [__] straw because of this
[__] because of throwing tires in the
ocean a turtle with a tire in its nose
and then guaranteed everybody's going to
come save Tire around his neck yeah dude
I recently saw this like re uh recycling
project where they try to get old tires
and then they grounded it up and then
they're making like AstroTurf and [__]
right and then they found out that all
these [__] kids are getting sick
because all the tires have all these
[__] up chemicals and [__] and and
then so like the kids are playing on the
playground sounds like the getting
[__] sick AstroTurf is all [__] it
up and it's like dude like yeah I don't
know if this is good guys yeah man
there's a lot how about figuring out a
great way to dispose of it instead of
repurposing toxic
[__] so there's still over 500,000 tires
left sitting at the bottom of the ocean
they're not deing quickly stupid is it
because they lost 1.5 million to the
[__] well no great scatter in that in
that area like in that area at the
bottom of the ocean there's 500,000
tires still left there's they estimated
that there were 650,000 tires remaining
in 2016 and then there were still over
500,000 in
2022 you know what this reminds me of it
reminds me of a stupid ass
environmentalists that are
like there's like a subset of them that
are very hardcore militant but also
really dumb and they don't like science
right so in C you know how we were
having a [__] ton of those Force fires
the reason why also and why it's so
intense is because environmentalists
don't let you uh cut the trees and they
don't let you do controlled fires so
like in nature you're supposed to have
forest fires for like the whole Force to
regenerate like it has to burn down it
has to like this the cycle replenish
otherwise it BEC a Tinder Box too yeah
and the fire department would do
controlled fires or they would just you
know you got to cut some trees down so
it minimizes the risk but then because
you can't do that they just grow [__]
wild and then out of control and then it
just takes one little spark even Gavin
new admitted that that's why they had a
problem with forest fires recently is
cuz they stopped doing the pruning
stupid it it seems like such a naive
like situation when you like this
example when you see that they clearly
needed somewhere to dump this [__] but
and then magically they came up with an
environmental initiative to do it how do
you not see the handshake how how do you
not see the [__] how about how about
huge corporations who who say we're
going to buy carbon credits what the
[__] is a carbon credit by the carbon
credit carbon credit things is such a
scam they basically say hey so um we're
going to like be dumping and doing a
bunch of [__] horrible things for the
environment but we bought like a bunch
of carbon credits so they're going to
like plant trees over there
that's what a car oh good so funny and
it's made billions of dollars oh totally
and it makes and all these companies
same thing Ryan's talking about they get
to pollute as much as they want and then
they get to write flowery [__] op-eds
about themselves and put them all over
Wall Street Journal and [__] even this
narrative if you're just like blind
coming into this and reading that most
people will probably think wow those
Engineers were stupid but it's like
those poor Engineers are the ones taking
the blame for the corporate decision
just the same way the corporations are
like hey all of Y fight amongst
yourselves about who's polluting more
will'll just be over the [__] all the
way over here it's like dude the more
that you fight with another just regular
Joe about it yep that's you're doing
exactly what they Jo's like yep yeah
don't fight with me I'm weaponizing
they're weaponizing people that care
about the environment yes yeah and then
the more dumb they are the more they
work for them well and dude the
corporate money the more corporate money
that goes in Cycles into these
environmental causes the more corrupt
they are I mean every [__] hey but
they're doing the real work though dude
they're [__] out there stopping cars
on the road they're [__] throwing
tomato soup on paint I like the tomato
soup on painting yeah that's probably
the best one or the glue the glue trees
yeah yeah they're they're doing the
[__] boots on the ground stuff gluing
their butts to the tarmac it's just like
once you see people arguing at all about
this with each other isn't that the
first sign of like wait why is that even
an element about this like corporate
succcess dude that's the are massive
corporations like why are regular people
fighting about where what bin they put
their compost in dude I was I was making
fun of Nikki's Aunt during Christmas
time cuz she like caught me not putting
a can in the recycling bin and and she
was like oh my God Steve you can't you
got to put it in C I'm like I'm like let
me ask you this ant M do you think they
trust you like do you think that they
don't check and have sorting facilities
for this like you oh you think they
trust you you think they they believe
that you're put everything accurately in
these [__] things like of course they
don't like they have to do that that's
why it's it's like a whole process that
they have to sort all this [__] out have
you ever actually seen the videos when
when they're at the recycling plant and
they'll be like oh yeah you see this
bottle of like Crystal guys or whatever
with like a they're like we can't
recycle this and they're like wait what
why like cuz it's got a paper label this
is a plastic machine it's like [__] like
that they'll be like oh you see that
it's got this cap this a different kind
of alloy we can't mix these together we
can't recycle it like there's so many
other reasons why certain products can't
be recycled and then it just gets like
tossed the side or sold or shipped to
another recycling place and just rotates
around it's so expensive dude in Japan
every [__] trash can is like eight
trash cans with every [__] Direction
on where you got to go so you got to
like dismantle a rifle every single time
you got
something but it's like wait that least
probably effective yeah if the whole
country subscribes to something and it's
like that's just the norm then it's got
to be [__] helpful you like American
would see those eight things and just go
ah [__] it just throw it on the
ground that's what I do American yeah
I'll use it if it's labeled I don't care
I'm recycle if it's labeled for sure but
at at at my aunt's house it wasn't or
for American instruction for Americans
to work it just needs to be a backboard
with a rim and they everyone just
goes lights go off every time you make
it it's why we need that little thing in
the urinal cuz cuz I will hit it yeah
but otherwise I don't know the little
fly yeah yeah you got to play to the
culture or like a little little poop
thing of poop I'm like oh yeah I'm going
to get you yeah that's God's work some
people don't do it some people are lazy
and they don't pee it off you got to pee
the poop off got to try to pee it off
sometimes you don't and then sometimes
you walk away and you go I just got to
get better next time I got to get better
next time but the real game is leaving
the seat down and still being able to
hit all the Poo yeah and then you leave
and then you're girlfriend's like what
the [__] did you do in
[Music]
here